je
là pour un anniversaire guéri et voeux
ou pour la nouvelle année pour que ce soit la guerre plus vite
terminé
[musique]
c'est que les parents brillants cette connexion
artema parent le
plage
[musique]
en semaine je vais faire mes devoirs
alors je viens ici
je suis en train de déjeuner
avec un autre je joue à des jeux sur le téléphone en ordinaire
jeux on ne joue pas aux cartes sur les cartes du monde
exactement oui et puis
des jeux de société oui il est avec moi
installation
là maintenant
ancre
chemin
[musique]
peut être
quand je me suis réveillé à partir de 7h j'ai eu peur
Je tremblais mais ensuite je me suis calmé
calmé le premier soir on est sur des chaises
dormi
alors nos parents
eh bien, les papas nous ont apporté un lit pour les enfants et nous
les enfants dormaient sur les lits et les parents sur
chaises
pour ton premier appelé mon père
là avec du travail ex bon
emballez vos papiers et parfois sur
Western ou bien, une autre raquette
bien envoyé il ne veut jamais partir nous
on va se coucher à Kharkov et le régime des premiers jours
Je ne m'inquiétais pas beaucoup, au début je ne l'ai pas fait
Je savais ce que c'était, je pensais juste que c'était
tout n'est pas vrai ça finira le lendemain
jour, mais après cela, j'ai déjà réalisé que je n'avais pas
le lendemain tout sera fini